muy buenos días para todos ustedes pues
una agenda bastante intensa porque es
una cumbre que tan solamente va a durar
este día viernes aquí este empezó muy
temprano esta mañana 9 de la mañana con
todas estas conferencias estas mesas
redondas acerca de todos esos temas que
usted viene de mencionar la educación la
democracia los deportes la cultura esto
aquí pues está supremamente lleno muy
concurrido este está esta cumbre hay
varias personalidades africanas entre
ellas varios deportistas de hecho que
pudimos ver vimos a el futbolista didier
drogba hace unos instantes aquí
presentes hace muchas expectativas por
parte del uso de las personas que están
participando acá de los jóvenes porque
esperan que a partir de ahora pues en
unas relaciones mucho más sinceras la
idea de esta cumbre sea esta finalmente
la de renovar las relaciones entre entre
francia y el continente africano así que
digamos que esa juventud africana lo que
quiere son relaciones mucho más sinceras
de hecho emanuel bach con quien llegó
esta mañana a esta cumbre y dónde va a
estar a lo largo de toda esta forma de
aquí decía que la no era olvidar el
pasado que une que los une pero si la de
poder avan de hecho presidente de manuel
marco estará participado en una plenaria
hacia la mitad de la tarde aquí en muy
feliz y será él quien pronuncie el
discurso de cierre un discurso muy
esperado también porque ahí se espera
haga varios anuncios y de hecho ya se
sabe que entre lo que va a anunciar pues
será la creación de un fondo para la
innovación de la democracia para apoyar
a los actores de la sociedad civil en
áfrica ya sea a través de la creación de
empresas pero también de actividades
culturales y deportivas precisamente
para promover eso un camino mucho más
firme pasos más firmes hacia la
democracia y para esto puede ser francia
otorgará unos 30 millones de euros